[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى حصاد الليله معكم في الوقت
الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من العراق تحديدا البصره حيث توج
العراق بكاس الخليج للمره الرابعه في
تاريخه
والى بغداد ومشاهد الاحتفالات التي تشهدها
العاصمه العراقيه
بتتويج المنتخب العراقي بالبطوله الخليجيه
عقب الفوز على سلطنه عمان
والى رام الله الان وهذه الصور بعد لقاءات
عقدها مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي مع
كبار المسؤولين الفلسطينيين على وقعه
صعيدا اسرائيليا في الضفه الغربيه
والى بيروت وهذه الصور بعد انهيار غير
مسبوق لليره اللبنانيه سعر الصرف لمس عتبه
50,000 ليره مقابل الدرهم
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
على ورقه تصيدا اسرائيليا يتسع في الضفه
الغربيه
الفلسطينيين على الساحه الدوليه هجوم
يستوجب الرد وعباس يطارد واشنطن بتدخل
فوري في وقف تصعيد الاحتلال
عشيه اجتماع ل 50 دوله في رانشتاين
بالمانيا تقارير عن تردد دول اوروبيه في
رفع الانفاق الدفاعي رغم التعهدي بدعم
عسكري جديد لاوكرانيا
كيف تحذر الغرب مما اسميته الارتجاف امام
بوتن الكريم الذي يحذر من تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه بعيده المدى يقول ان ريهانا ليتو
على هزيمه قوه النوويه مثل روسيا يعني
احتمالا دلاله حرب نوويه
منتريس الى تولوز مرسيليا ومونبليه وتور
ومدن اخرى
[موسيقى]
اضربه واسعه النطاق ومظاهره في فرنسا
احتجاجا على تعديل نظام التقاعد
والستوترات الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه جبهه
موحده للنقابات الرئيسيه للمره الاولى منذ
12 عاما ومكرون يتمسك بالقانون الجديد
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا سياق وتوقيت تسجيل
النيره اللبنانيه اليوم مستوى منخفضا غير
مسبوق عند ال 50,000 ليره للدولار ما يعني
تراجعا في قيمته في اكثر من
95% منذ انهيار النظام المالي في لبنان
عام 2019
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثالث في الانهيار القياسي
الليره اللبنانيه في هذا التوقيت النتيجه
جاءت على النحو الثانيه
نحو 6% قالوا ان السبب هو تعثر قرض صندوق
النقد في حين رجح نحو 12 في المئه ان يكون
السبب هو غياب الدعم الدولي لبنان بينما
صوت نحو 82% لصالح القول من السبب هو
انقسام الطبقه السياسيه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الذي يظهر
الامرصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا نتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوله
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
للمره الرابعه في تاريخه العراق يتوج
ببطوله خليجي 25 لكره القدم اثرا فوزه على
سلطنه عمان بثلاثه اهداف الاثنين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال البيت الابيض ان المستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيك سلفن اكد للمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين مواصله اداره دعم حل
الدولتين
وضروره تجنب اي خطوات احاديه تؤجل التوتر
على الارض وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو قال خلال محادثاته مع
صالبا في القدس ان تحركات الفلسطينيين على
الساحه الدوليه هجوم على اسرائيل
يستدعي رده بينما طالب الرئيس الفلسطيني
لدى لقائه المسؤول الامريكي بتدخل فوري من
واشنطن لوقف تصعيد اسرائيل
جاك سوليفان اول وارفع شخصيه سياسيه
امريكيه يلتقي اقطاب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده
الموصوفه بالاكثر تطرفا سياسيا ودينيا
ياتي مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي وفق
مصادر امريكيه موثوقه حاملا رساله تحذير
لحكومه
اتخاذ اي خطوات من شانها القضاء على رؤيه
الدولتين وتقويض السلطه الفلسطينيه وان
ظهر الضيف والمضيف امام كاميرات الصحفيين
بتصريحات وديه ودبلوماسيه
قضايا الامن القومي وبالطبع في فرص
السلامه
ملتزمه بدعم اسرائيل بشكل قوي وهذا التزام
متجذر في التاريخ
صالحي والقيم المشتركه طرحت اجنده وسعه
لنا واتفق معكم ان علينا الحديث عن كافه
التحديات المشتركه نجحت الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ولو مؤقتا في تجميد مناقشه خطه
لبناء وحده الاستيطانيه في مستوطنه
نفتسيون في القدس المحتله كي لا يلقي ذلك
بظلاله على زياره سوليفان لكنه يبقى امرا
متواضعا حيال مطالب الفلسطينيين التي
استمع اليها الضيف الامريكي
ضروره ممارسه الضغط امريكي حقيقي لوقف
جميع الاجراءات احاديه الجانب غير
القانونيه وفي مقدمتها الاستيطان
واقتحامات المناطق الفلسطينيه والاعدامات
الميدانيه وهدم المنازل وتهويد القدس
والمقدسات وايضا ضروره بذل جهد امريكي
حقيقي من اجل استعاده الافق السياسي لحل
الصراع وياتي سوليفان لتبديد المخاوف التي
تعتري واشنطن من خطوات اسرائيليه لتوسيع
الاستيطان وضم في المناطق المصنفه جيم في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله الى جانب التاكد من
ان حكومه اليمين لن تفاجئ الاداره
الامريكيه باي تحرك عسكري بشان ملف ايران
النووي مع تعثر التوصل اتفاق جديد مع طهرا
لا يحمل جاكسون في جعبته ايا خطه امريكيه
لاطلاق عمليه سياسيه جديده لكنه يسعى كما
يبدو الى نزع فتيل اي تصعيد محتمل في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ووقف اجراءات
اسرائيليه قد تفجر الموقف
برمته». القدس المحتله
وعندما الان الينا من رام الله الدكتور
هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
اسياسات ومن واشنطن الدكتور
وهو المدير السابق للتعاون والانخراط
الدولي لحل الازمات في البيت الابيض خلال
اداره الرئيس الاسبق اوباما اهلا بكم في
الحصاد ابدا معك
الى المنطقه في وقت التصعيد الاسرائيلي
على اشده
واوع
قادم ليقدم تحذير شديد اللهجه من الرئيس
فايتين
بان على الرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ان يكون
حريصا ودقيقه وبصراحه لا بد ان يخيب
واعضاء
اي خطوات متطرفه واستفزازات اتخذوها هذا
التواصل ما قبل الازمه واعتقد سنشهد
المزيد من ذلك حيث ان الامريكان سيحولون
التدخل لمنع
الامور هل سينجح في ذلك هل ان نتنه وزراء
سيصغرون الى ما يقول له ما زال هذا السؤال
المفتوحا دكتور هاني المصري هل في ما
يحمله جيكسا التوقيت الطريق اي شيء يمكن
ان نجعلنا نعتقد ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
سيستمع هذه المره
اعتقد اننا لا يمكن ان نتوقع شيئا جادا من
هذه الزياره لان حتى التصريحات التي
اطلقها سوليفا تؤكد على العلاقه
الاستراتيجيه والالتزام بالدعم المطلق
لاسرائيل ولامن اسرائيل وكل ما هنالك ان
الاداره الامريكيه تريد ان تلعب دور سياره
الاسعاف لا تمنع يعني القتل لا تمنع
الاستيطان لا تمنع تغيير مكانه الاقصى لا
تمنع يعني عمليات تغيير النظام في اسرائيل
لان هذه الحكومه لا تقصر في اهدافها على
الفلسطينيين وانما تريد ان تغير النظام
يعني الاسرائيلي لكي تصبح اسرائيل دوله
دينيه اكثر تطرفا لا يوجد فيها اي هوامش
لبراليه وهذا الذي يسبب يعني معارضه واسعه
داخل اسرائيل فبالتالي حديث سلفا عن
التزام الاداره الامريكيه بحل الدولتين
ومنع تقويضه هذه يعني مجرد ضريبه كلاميه
لان ما يجري على الارض قوض منذ زمن بعيد
حل الدولتين الان هناك اكثر من 900.000
مستعمل مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه وهناك
مخططات مقربه ببرنامج الحكومه
تلزم الحكومه الاسرائيليه نفسها بان هناك
حق حصري لليهود بالاستيطان في كل الاراضي
بما في ذلك في الجولان وتبييض وشرعنه
الاستيطانيه خلال مده محدده محدده في
البرنامج لذلك لا معناها لمثل هذا الكلام
مجرد كلام بدون ممارسه الضغوط بدون
استخدام سلاح العقوبات سلاح الدعم الذي
تقدمه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاسرائيل هذه الفكره البريد الالكتروني
اذا هل سيظل الموقف الامريكي حديث الاعراب
عن القلق
والتحذير هل سياخذ منحا اكثر تاثيرا انصح
القول او اكثر
باي شكل من الاشكال
هو وهي مشكله واشنطن
هو انه ليس هناك من ناحيه اساسيه او اوامر
كثيرا كنا يقدمه لهم
الولايات المتحده هذا موضوع حساس جدا
وطبعا الان لدينا مجلس النواب الذي اصبح
تحت سيطره الجمهوريين يقوموند الجلسات
استماع
يحاسبون كل ما تقوم به
الاداره عندما يتعلق باي التغيرات في
سياسه اسرائيل ولكن رغم ذلك هناك بعض
الخيارات طبعا هناك خيارات تروح بين
المراجعه الدبلوماسيه الى الى اقتراح بان
الولايات المتحده لن
ربما لن لن
تقدم نفس المزايا
وامكانيات الوصول لوزاره البيت الابيض او
الزيارات كبيره
لو طالما تحدوا ونجوا بفعلتهم والان همم
لا يتوقع اكثر من هذا مجرد يعني تحذير انت
قلتها سياره اسعاف على الاقل كما وصفت كما
يبدو ولكن
التصعيد الذي حصل في الفتره الاخيره هل
يمكن ان يامل الفلسطينيين ان يكون لي هذه
زياره لتثير همم ربما في التخفيض المستوى
نعم هم سيحاولون تخفيف المستوى ولكن اذا
اقدمت اسرائيل على تنفيذ برنامج الحكومه
لن تقوم الاداره الامريكيه بممارسه
العقوبات او المقاطعه او استخدام سلاح
الدعم المالي على سبيل المثال والمزايا
التي تمنحها بشكل سخيل لاسرائيل لذلك انصح
الفلسطينيون والعرب بان لا يبالغوا في
الرهان على الاداره الامريكيه بل لا
يراهنوا ابدا يراهنوا اساسا على انفسهم
اذا اتخذ الفلسطينيون سياسه فعليه تقاطع
هذه الحكومه وتطالب بعزلها وتسعى من اجل
جبهه عالميه لاسقاطها همم يمكن عندها
العالم ان يتحرك اذا عاد الفلسطينيون
النظر بالالتزامات المترتبه على اتفاق
اوسلو مثل الاعتراف باسرائيل مثل التنسيق
الامني مثل التبعيه الاقتصاديه اذا نظم
الفلسطينيون عمليه مقاومه مثمره شامله
بالاراضي الفلسطينيه هذا سيحدث الاثر لان
ميدان المعركه الرئيسي هو في الارض
الفلسطينيه عندما يكون هناك مقاومه فعاله
فهذا سيدفع الاداره الامريكيه وسيدفع
المجتمع الدولي وسيدفع العرب للتحرك بشكل
جاد بدون ذلك مجرد ان نطالب الاداره
الامريكيه او نطالب المجتمع الدولي
بالحمايه وبالتحرك فنحن نطالب يعني منذ
عشرات السنين ويجب ان يتغير هذا المسار
هذا المسار وصل الى طريق مسدود واصبح هناك
ضروره ملحه لتغييره قبل فوات الاوان لان
هذه الحكومه تريد ان تحسن الصراع تعتقد
انها قادره على حسن الصراع واذا لم ترتفع
منذ البدايه ستقوم بتنفيذ الدكتور
المتطرفه التي تعد الامور لها لها
الاداره الامريكيه من خلال التصرفات
والطريقه التي تعاملت فيها مع الفلسطينيين
قد تكون همم
اجبرات او دفعتهم الى اخذ مثل هذه المواقف
الى اي درجه يمكن ان تتحمل طبيعات ذلك
فعلا لديه فرص اكثر
فيمكن ان تدخل بشكل قوي وتعلم مع
الفلسطيني بشكل اقوى
اجتماعات يمكن
تزيد وترفع موقف الفلسطينيه
في الفيديو
ما هو الطريق ما هو الطريق في هذه الاوقات
العصيبه في محليا
وسيعود الى واشنطن بلا شكوى ويحمل بعض
التوصيات حول المناطق الاشياء اللي ممكن
يقوموا بشيء
الدولي في البيت الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس
مبارك اوباما وشكرا لدكتور هاني المصري
مدير مركز مسارات لابحث السياسات
تزامنا مع محادثات مستشار الامن القومي في
الاراضي المحتله وصلت اسرائيل التصعيد ضد
الفلسطينيين اذ قتلت قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الفلسطينيين ادهم جبارين وجواد
بواقنا واصابه ثلاثه اخرين خلال حمله
اعتقالات في مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
قبل ساعات من اجتماع وزراء دفاعي حلف شمال
الاطلسي في مدينه رامشتاين الالمانيه
تعهدت عشر دول اوروبيه بتقديم مساعدات
هجوميه لاوكرانيا المانيا ليست من بين هذه
الدول امر دفع الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
ميرسي الى انتقاد تردد برلين في ارسال
الدبابات لبرد التي تقول كيف انها في امس
الحاجه اليها في معاركها في هذا السياق
فان التقى وزير الدفاع الامريكي لوليد
اوستن مع نظيره الالماني في برلين وبحثا
مساله تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
الدبابات القادمه من الغرب مفتاح سحريه في
المعارك تبحث عنه اوكرانيا الاعين
الاوكرانيه على دبابات تشالنجر من
بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
من المانيا
الاوكراني خصوصا في المناطق الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه هذه الحاجه تنتقل الان
من الدفاع الى الهجوم تتجاوزكي الحديث عن
استعاده مساحات من القبضه الروسيه الى
استهداف شبه جزيره القرد توضع شبه الجزيره
الجنوبيه على الطاوله احد الاهداف القادمه
للقوات الاوكرانيه رغم السيطره الروسيه
عليها منذ عام 2014
[موسيقى]
الى
موافقه الدوله المصنعه
تقترح عدد من الدول الاوروبيه في الناتو
رساله دبابات المانيه الصنع تتقدم بولندا
وفنلندا ودول البلطيق بالاقتراح وهي تملك
هذه الدبابات لكنها بحاجه لموافقه المانيه
تعلن بريطانيا ارسالها عدد من دبابات
تشالنجر لكن كيف تريد المزيد يبدو الطريق
غير سالك امام وصول الدبابات الالمانيه
والامريكيه الى جبهات القتال تشترط
المانيا لارسال دباباتها ارسال الولايات
المتحده دباباتها اولا هذا ما تنقله صحيفه
وليتكو عن المستشار الالماني لكن الرجل
يبرر موقفه بالخشيه من الخراط نيته في
الصراع بشكل مباشر تعلل الولايات المتحده
عدم ارسال دباباتها بان الامر يحتاج وقتا
طويلا من التدريب وخشيه من عدم قدره
الاخرانيين على الصيانه
في هذه الازمه المتواصله تتدفق المساعدات
العسكريه الغربيه على اوكرانيا يجتمع
وزراء الدفاع لعدد من دول النيترو من
ضمنهم الوزير البريطاني ويعلنون عن تقديم
المساعدات تتضمن دبابات ويلتقي في الوقت
نفسه وزير الدفاع الامريكي نظيره
الالمانيه في برلين ويشكره على الدعم لكن
بعيدا عن عدسات الكاميرات يتواصل الجدل
ولا انباء عن حل الخلاف حتى الان امام هذا
الجدل الامريكي الالماني والاوروبي
الالماني يغضب الرئيس الاوكراني وينتقد
المانيا على الملعب
لا تتردد وليست هناك حاجه للمقارنه اذا
قلت انك ستعطي الدبابات شرط ان يقدم شخص
اخر الدبابات ايضا يبدو لي ان هذه ليست
استراتيجيه صحيحه
ينتقد رئيس الوزراء الهولندي انتقاد
زينسكي لالمانيا انتقاد المانيا ليس صحيحا
المانيا ومنذ بدايه الحرب قدمت الكثير من
الدعم المالي والمعدات
هكذا تصير المواجهه الغربيه
في تفاصيل عسكريه قد تقلب المعادله على
الارض وقد تؤخر الحزن لكنها في الوقت نفسه
قد تحرك مسار الحرب الى طرق مفتوحه
الخيارات
[موسيقى]
التي تريدها اوكرانيا والتي وعدت بعض
العواصم الاوروبيه بتزويد كبها فالعرض
التالي محمد رجب الضوء على انواع الدبابات
ونقلات الجلد والمنظومات الصاروخيه
المرتقب ان تشارك في جبهات القتال بين
روسيا محمد
لا يمكن تعويله على سلاح واحد لخوض الحروب
والانتصار فيها لذلك نجد الحديث دائما عن
الحاجه الى انواع جديده من الاسلحه حسب
نوع المعارك المراد خوضها مؤخرا سمعنا
كثيرا عن طلب اوكرانيا لدبابات ليوبارد
اثنين الالمانيه هذه الدبابات متطوره
وتطابق معايير نيته لكن ليس هدف حزب هو
سبب هناك سبب
دبابات التي تعاني اوكرانيا نقصا فيها
قديفه دبابات ليوبارد من عيار 180 مليمترا
هذه القذائف تصنع في دول النيتو على نطاق
واسعا ويمكن تزويد اوكرانيا بها لكن هناك
مشكله
الاصول الرئيسي للدبابات اوكرانيا هو من
طراز تي 72
السوفياتيه
والمتهالكه الان هذه الدبابات لا تستخدم
قذائف من عيار 120 وانما قد افا من عيار
125 ولا يوجد مناطق تصنيع كافيه له
واذا كان بامكان النيترو تزويد اوكرانيا
بالقذائف فليس لديها الدبابات التي يمكنها
استخدام هذه القذائف
كثر الحديث ايضا عن زياده في منظومه هاي
مارس التي يبلغ مدى صواريخها نحو 90
كيلومترا هذه المنظومه لديها صواريخ موجهه
واستخدمت بشكل رئيسيا لاستهداف خطوط امداد
الروسيه ومراكز القياده في الجبهات
واشارت تقارير الى انها اثرت في مجريات
المعارك بشكل كبير كما يجري الحديث عن دعم
اوكرانيا بناقلات الجنود من نوال سترايكر
وتحاول دول النيدو بهذا النسيج من الاسلحه
تعزيز القدرات الاخرانيات على اختراق
الدفاعات الروسيه في الجبهات عبر تعزيز
القوه الناريه وقدرات المناوره
الرئيس الروسي السابق ديمتري مد فيادف ان
هزيمه قوه نوويه في حرب تقليديه قد تشعر
حرب النوويه في اشاره الى حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بينما حذر المتحدث الغرب من
خطوره امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه تمكنها من
ثمن هجمات على ارض روسيا ووصف هذا الامر
بشديد الخطوره وبانه سينقل الصراع لمستوى
جديد وقال بسكوف ان امداد اوكرانيا بهذا
النوع من الاسلحه سيعني رفع مستوى الصراع
الى درجه نوعيه جديده لا تبشر بالخير ازاء
الامن لعمومي اوروبا
ينضم الان الينا من روما السفير
اليساندرومنوتوريزو نائب الامين العام
السابق لحلف الناتو اهلا بك في الحصاد
السيد من التريزو ابدا معك من
التهديدات من الانتقادات من الاختلافات
ماذا تتوقع من رامز
الانطباع العام الذي كان سائدا كان يقوم
على اساس انه من الممكن التوصل الى نوع من
التسويه في الحرب نفسها ثم بعد ذلك
تراجع تلك الكلام لان اذا كنا نتحدث عن
تفاوض وحل تفاوضي لا يمكن في نفس الوقت
توفير وارسال اسلحه لكن ما حصل في
الاسبوعين الماضين تقريبا
ساده الانطباع مره اخرى بان روسيا ستبقى
في هذه الحرب لامد طويل وان روسيا ستبدا
باستدعائه الشباب للخدمه والاستمرار في
الحرب والتعبئه وانها تريد تحقيق النصر
على اوكرانيا هذا هو الانطباع الذي ساد
اذا ردهم على هذا الامر الحكومه
الاوكرانيه الان تطالب بشده بدعم لانهم
يشعرون انهم لن يستطيعوا البقاء والنجاه
ما لم يقم الغرب واقصد بالغرب حلف الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي
بدعمهم بالطبع بالنسبه للقاء رامز تايم
غدا سيحضر حوالي 50 بلدا هذا عددا كبير
هذا يعني ان اعضاء الناتو اضافه الى بلدان
الاخرى سيبحثون امورا كثيره حسب تقدير
سيكون القرار النهائي بارسال المزيد من
السلاح استجابه لمناشده الحكومه
الاوكراني لكن طبعا هناك تاويلات مختلفه
في الجانب الاوروبي وهناك همم كما قلتم
المانيا مثلا على سبيل المثال
تتردد في ارسال
الدبابات من اجيال متقدمه لا ادري ماذا
سيكون قرار المانيا النهائي
وربما مواقف اخرى همم تصب في نفس الاطار
هل همم سببه خوف من عواقب التحذيرات
الروسيه الان هل تحسب حساب لذلك ام تحسب
حساب لوضع اقتصادي متردد داخلي ما هو
المحرك الاساسي في هذا التردد برايك
[موسيقى]
هناك
وجهت النظر مختلف
الامور طبعا انا اقول ابسط لكن ربما هناك
اختلافات اكثر من هذا لكن مبسطه الامور
يمكن ان نقول هناك
يقوم على اساس انك اذا ما قاومت ولم تصر
في النهايه
تاتي تسويه ربما هذا رايي يميل اليه
الالمان الفرنسي لكن مثلا غيرهم من
الاسبان قد يكون موقفهم مختلفا وهنا وجهه
نظر اخرى تقوم على اساسي
شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا مره
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا التي تعود النقابات فيها لتتصدر
المشهد وتخرج
الى الشارع يخرج انصارها الى الشارع في
محاوله لايقاف خطط الحكومه الهادفه الى
رفع سن التقاعد مئات الالاف من الفرنسيين
بدعوه من النقابات الكبرى يخرجون للتظاهر
احتجاجا تزامنا مع اضرابات شملت قطاعات
حيويه كالصحه والنقل والمدارس والمصافي
النقابات اعتبرت ان استجابه الفرنسيين
لدعوات الاضراب مؤشرا على رفض الشارع لخطه
الحكومه في ما وصف الرئيس القانون المثيره
للجدل بالعدل والضروري لاستمرار عمل
صناديق المعاشات
[موسيقى]
في ما يبدا اختبار سياسيا واقتصاديا هو
الاصعب بالنسبه للرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون بعد اقل من ثمانيه اشهر على ولايته
الثانيه
الى الشارع مئات الالاف من العمال
والموظفين اختاروا سلاح الاضراب عن العمل
ورفع الصوت عاليا رفضا لمشروعي حكومته
الساعي لاصلاح نظام التقاعد والذي ينصه في
ابرز تعديلاته على رفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما بدلا من 62
عديده وابرزه النقل والصحه والطاقه
والتعليم
وتسبب في تعطيل حركه المواصلات وخفض انتاج
الكهرباء واغلاق المدارس في عدد من مدن
البلاد كما امتنع عاملونها في وسائل
الاعلام حكوميه وموظفونها في وزاره
الخارجيه عن العمل
وفق استطلاعات الرئيس ان خطه ماكرون تواجه
رفضا لدى الراي العام ومعارضه من احزاب
اليسار واليمين المتطرف وهو ما اظهره
التجارب الكبير مع دعوات النقابات
الرئيسيه الثماني في البلاد التي تحركت
ضمن جبهه الموحده للمره الاولى منذ 12
عاما
هذه الاحتجاجات لا يمكن الا ان تشتد وتوسع
الكره في ملعب الحكومه انه مشروعهم واذا
سحب لن يكون هناك تعبئه نحن جاهزونا
ولدينا حلول بشان كيفيه تحسين النظام
الحالي وليس تغييره او جعلنا نعمل لفتره
اطول
في المقابل تعتبر الحكومه ومن خلفها
الرئيس ماكرون ان مشروعهم الاصلاح خطوه لا
مفر منها للضمان عدم افلاسين نظام التقاعد
فتمديده فتره العمل هو الخيار الامثل
لمواجهه التدهور الماليه للصناديق التقاعد
وشيخوخه الس
في اللحظات التي تقل فيها اعداد الاشخاص
النشيطين اقتصاديا ويتزايد عدد المتقاعدين
اكثر فاكثر اذا كنت تريد ان يكون الميثاق
بين الاجيال منصفا فيجب تنفيذ هذا الاصلاح
لقاباتي تجادل بان هناك وسائل اخرى لضمان
استمرار نظام التقاعد مثل فرض ضرائب على
فاحشه الثراء او زياده مساهمات اصحاب
العمل او مساهمات اصحاب الرواتب العاليه
في حين يكمل الاختبار الثاني لرئيس ماكرون
بان المشروع الحكومي سيمر الى الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه التي لا يملك فيها
الاغلبيه المطلقه
[موسيقى]
تتاثر الدول الافريقيه سلبا جراء عدم
الاستقرار في ليبيا خاصه الدول الحدوديه
منها تتدفق الاسلحه والمرتزقه ومختلفه
فصائل المعارضه لدول الافريقيه الى صحراء
جنوب ليبيا وتتغدى هذه الدول بالاسلحه
المنطلقه
من يناير الجاري وفي الاجتماع التحضيري
للمصالحه الوطنيه الليبيه اكد رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي رئيس جمهوريه السنغال
اكد دعم الاتحاد لاي حل شامل للازمه في
ليبيا الحديث عن دور المفوضيه الافريقيه
في حل الازمه يسعدنا ان نحب من اديس ابابا
البروفيسور محمد الحسن لبات مدير ديوان
رئيس
الافريقيه ورئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه
الافريقيه للمصالحه الوطنيه الليبيه اهلا
بك في الحص وابدا معك من المبادئ التي
تحكم همم تدخل الاتحاد الافريقي في
المصالحه الليبيه تفضل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه على النبي
الكريم اا احسنت في البدايه بهذه النقطه
فهي نقطه حاسمه بالغه الاهميه وباختصار
شديد نظرا لضيق الوقت بان هذه المبادئ
يمكن ان نلخصها في اربع نقاط
النقطه الاولى همم المبدا الاول يمكن ان
نسميه وتشبه في الاتحاد الافريقي بمبدا
ضروره حل المشاكل والازمات الافريقيه
بالجهود الافريقيه دون اللجوء الى تدخلات
الاجنبيه بالمعارضه التدخلات الاجنبيه
المبدا الثاني ايضا لحل هذه الازمات هو
انها لا تحل بالترك العسكريه وانما تحل
بالترك السلميه
الثالث وهو انه في طريقه السعي الى ايجاد
ذلك الحل السياسي همم يلزموا ان تشارك
تشارك كل الفرقاء في السعي في البحث عن
ذلك الحل
عيوني اي اقصاء فمبدا رفضي الاقصاء في
السعي الى بلوره الحلول السلميه الى
الازمات الافريقيه هو مبدا همم اكيد
والمبدا الرابع هو ضروره وهو مسجل مع
المبادئ يعني بيت الذكر هو مبدا ضروره
التملك كل شعب من الشعوب الافريقيه لمئاله
الوطنيه والقومي وبالتالي يكون من هذه من
هذا المنطلق دوره الاتحاد الافريقي مثلا
في ملف المصالح الذي نحن بصدد الحديث يعني
وليس دعما اطلاقا لحل اهله اذا انطلاقا من
هذه المبادئ التي اشرت اليها الاربعه تاتي
جهود الاتحاد الافريقي في التركيز على
المصالحه الوطنيه بينما الغرب بشكل عام
تتركز جهوده في الملف السياسي الانتخابات
ربما ايضا توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه هل هناك
تباين او تضارب بين هذه الجهود
قد لا يكون هنالك تضارب بالمعنى الدقيق
الكلمه او صدام للكلمه ولكننا نحن نقول
بالمقوله التي نفاذها ان المصالحه
المصالحه الوطنيه هي مساله المركزيه في
السعي من اجل الحالي نحن نعتقد انه من باب
العبث ان همم نتوصل الى
سياسيه تحل الازمه حلا نهائيا ومستديا ما
لم تتم المصالحه لذلك وقد عرفنا عن هذا
الموقف الامم المتحده وللترا في الليبيين
وسنظل حريصين على احترام مركزيه المصالحه
الوطنيه في تاسيسي حل قابل للبقاء في همم
ليبيا الشقيقه ولكن لاي همم مدى تعتقدون
ان فعلا المصالحه الوطنيه تلقى هذا القبول
في صفوف همم
الاطراف المختلفه خصوصا ان في ملتقى اخير
كان هناك
المصالحه الوطنيه عقده المجلس الرئاسي كان
هناك اختلاف على النشيد والعلم
فاذا كنا في هذا الوارد كيف يمكن ان يتوقع
ان يسير هذا الملف قدوما
كنتم في قلب الحدث
الاتحاد الافريقي المشكله من وزير
الخارجيه همم الكونغو التي تتركز اللجنه
الربيعه المستوى للشيخ الليبي الشخصيه
المتواضع والممثلين الاتحاد الافريقي في
ليبيا وغيرها من الشخصيات الافريقيه
ساهمنا في هذا المؤتمر في اعدادي هذه
الاجتماع في اعداده وفي عقده وفي تسيره
وفي التصدي لبعده همم المشاهدات التي حدثت
فيه اود ان يقول هنا بهذا الصدر ان مساله
همم المسائل الخلافيه التي يذكر من بينها
الخلافه حول العالم والنشيد هذا حديث
المبالغه فيه الى حد كبير
فالراي والسائد والذي تم اقراره والذي
دافع عنه الاتحاد الافريقي هو ان النشيد
ولا على مره هنا يبقى يعني كما هما الى ان
يقرر الشعب اللي في اقترا همم على دستور
الجديد واقتراع خاص للمسالتين ثم عندها
همم سيتم اقرار ما يصادق عليه الشعب
الليبي ولكن الى ذلك التاريخ يبقى العالم
الراهن ويبقى النشيد الراهب وهذه مساله لم
يكون فيها خلاف كبير واعتقد ان الذين اثار
تساؤلات حول هذه المسالتين في النهايه
اتخذوا المواقف يشد ايجابيه ولصالحه
المصالحه الوطنيه وهذا الشيء يحسب لهم
سياسي
افريقيا
عبد الله باتيلي الى اي حد يمكن ان يلعب
دور في ملفات علاقه مثل المرتزقه التي
ياتي بعضهم من دول افريقيه كذلك والهجره
غير النظاميه التي تمر في غالبها من ليبيا
بكل تاكيد كمان شرطي في المقدمه ليبيا
الان هي
تضافر فيها كثير تظافر وهي كثير منها
عناصر العناصر السالبه سواء كانت الهجره
سواء كانت
عناصر متطرفه سواء كانت لعيب دوليه الى
اخره
اصطدام بين المصالح الى اخره هذا صحيح وفي
هذه الظروف يصبح تعين شخصيه افريقيا لتولي
مهمه اداره
اجازه الامم المتحده شيء مشجع بالنسبه
للاتحاد الافريقي
والشجاعناهم لاننا امر من خلاله ان يكون
هناك همم شراكه وتعاون همم على الارض على
الارض همم يعكس في التعاونه همم القيم
الذي هو قائم بينه وظيفه الاتحاد الافريقي
اداره الاتحاد الافريقي بسياره عامه
الامين العام للامم المتحده على مستوى همم
المنظمه الدوليه وقد نقاشات مثمره مع سيد
عبد الله باتليل وصديق شخصي نعرفه يعرفه
قادته همم الاتحاد الافريقي سواء كان على
مستوى الرئاسه الدوليه الدوليه او على
مستوى مفوض المفوضيه وبالتالي همم هذا
عنصر مشجع واا
قد ايه حضر اختتام لايام التحضيريه
للمؤتمر الجامع التي اقيمت بنجاح اخيرا في
ليبيا وعندما اقول نجاح هذا لا يعني نجاح
مطلقه
حول هذا الاجتماع
المفوضيه الافريقيه ورئيس اللجنه
الاستشاريا الافريقيه للمصالحه شكرا
[موسيقى]
توجه المنتخب العراقي بكاس الخليج للمره
الرابعه في تاريخه بفوزه على نظيره
العماني بثلاثه اهداف لهدفين في المباراه
النهائيه
كاس الخليج كان المنتخب العراقي يطمح الى
تحقيق لقبه الرابع في البطوله امام
المنتخب العماني الذي كان يبحث عن ثالث
تتويج له
اول تهديد عراقيه جاء عن طريق علي فايز
بهذه المخالفه
ورد العمانيون بتسديده صلاح لاحياء التي
تصدى لها الحارس جلال حسن
وعند الدقيقه الرابعه والعشرين افتتح
ابراهيم بايش النتيجه لمصلحه المنتخب
العراقي
في الشوط الثاني سدد حسين علي خارج اطار
المرمى
ثم حصل منتخب عمان على ركله جزاء تصدى لها
الحارس جلال حسن
وفي الوقت بدل الضائع اعلن حكم المباراه
عن ركله جزاء ثانيه لعمان حولها صلاح
اليحيى الى هدف التعادل فمتدت المباراه
الى شوطين اضافيين
سجل امجد عطوان هدفا ثانيا للعراق من ركله
جزاء اخرى في الدقيقه السادسه عشر بعد
المئه
ولم تمر خمس دقائق حتى ادرك عمر المالكي
التعادل لعمان
لكن منافيونس احرز هدف الفوز للعراق في
الوقت بدل الضائع
ليتوج المنتخب العراقي
بلقبه الخليجي الرابع
مباراه لعبت باعصاب الجميع اللي مزيد عن
تداعياتها وما قالت الي ينضم الينا من
البصره احمد الجاسم من بغداد
يوسف احمد وسامر اهلا بكم في الحصاد احمد
ابدا معك كيف هي الاجواء في البطه
المنتخب العراقي
الذي قام الذي قامت به احتفالات تتويج
المنتخب العراقي همم الجماهير العراقيه
هنا في شط العرب بدات الاحتفالات همم
من ثور ثور فوز المنتخب العراقي
وتتويجه لديه هنا العديد من الجماهير
السعيدين بهذا الفوز الذي الذي حققوه
المنتخب العراقي اولا الف مبروك الفوز
اليوم مباراه كانت تحمل كثير من التوتر
كيف كان همم كيف رايته والله المباراه
جميله اول شيء حي قناه الجزيره قناتكم
مباركه اللي دائما همم موجوده بالتقطيع
شيء ثاني حي شعب العماني او شيء ثالث حي
شعبي همم بالفوز والف الف مبروك وكانت
مباراه جدا جميله والشعب فرحان والجماهير
كلها فرحانه الميئات من العراق
للاحتفال بهذا الفوز همم قد يكون قد تكون
الاحتفالات تستمر الى نصف الليل هنا شفت
الفوز
بعد ما عندي شعر للمنتخب
قول هلا بالرده والفرح الوطن
هلا بالرده والفرح الوطن
مهمومين بس هسه ساعدنا وفوز المنتخب
فوز المنتخب ترتاح القلوب
[موسيقى]
فوز المنتخب ترتاحي القلوب فرعون فرعون
[تصفيق]
شكرا لك
الاجواء في بغداد ايضا نسمع منك
مشتعله ليلى الاجواء هنا حيث واقف في ساحه
التحرير تحديدا وحتى في مناطقه اخرى من
بغداد الصوره تتكلم هنا ليله في طبيعه
الحال همم الالاف
والتجمعوا هنا في ساحه التحرير قبل اا
انطلاق المباراه بساعات واستمروا همم هنا
يشاهدون المباراه
عبر شاشه عملاقه نصبت هنا عند نصب همم
الحريه في وسط بغداد وفي مناطق اخرى من
العاصمه همم بغداد همم الشوارع
بالعراقيين الذين يحتفلون في هذا الفوز
وهمم ويرددون الاغاني وينتهجون همم تحقيق
الكاس الرابعه في بطوله خليجي 25 تحديدا
التي اقيمت في البصره وبدات سادس من يناير
همم الحالي لالعاب الناريه هنا همم موجوده
رايات اعلام العراق ايضا موجوده وسط
انتشار امني ايضا كثيف في الساحه وفي عموم
مناطق بغداد التي اصبحت مكتظه بالمشجعين
وبالعراقيين الذين يحتفلون بمناسبه هذا
الفوز هذه اذا الصوره همم حتى الان
حتى
بغداد وغيرها من همم مدن العراق ستستمر
شكرا جزيلا لك سامر يوسف شكرا لك شكرا
طبعا لاحمد جاسم من البصره
[موسيقى]
عوده الان الى موضوع امدادات السلاح
الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا التهيمن اربع دول على
خريطه الصناعه العسكريه في اوروبا هي
فرنسا المانيا وبريطانيا وايطاليا وتعتبر
مبيعات الاسلحه احدى اهم مصادر الدخل في
تلك البلدان
فرنسا طبعا المرتبه الثالثه عالميا في
تصدير السلاح بنحو احد 10% هي اول بلد
يرسل اسلحه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا من دبابات
متراس ايمكس
اما المانيا فهي خامس مصدر للاسلحه عالميه
وتعاد دبابات ليوبارد التي تتردد برلين في
تزويد بها عماد الصناعه العسكريه المانيا
اما الصناعات العسكريه البريطانيه ايضا
تحظى بمكانه مهمه اوروبيا وعالميا وتعد
دبابه تشالنجر تحديدا فخر هذه الصناعه
وتستعد لندن لارسال اربعه عشر دبابات منها
الى اوكرانيا
طبعا مثل كل القطاعات فقد تاثرت
الصناعه العسكريه الاوروبيه بالحرب على
اوكرانيا وقررت معظم البلدان زياده
الانفاق العسكري تحسبا للاسوا ولمواكبه
احتياجات كيف
قررت المانيا تخصيص 100 مليار يورو اضافيه
للجيش مع زياده المستدامه في الميزانيه
العسكريه بنسبه اثنين في المئه من الناتج
المحليه الالماني وهذا رقم ضخم جدا
بريطانيا اعلانات زياده في ميزانيه الدفاع
بنحو مليار
و400 ب 400 مليون جنيه استرليني لتصبح 50
مليار جنيه خلال السنه الماليه 2023 2004
فرنسا قررت في مارس الماضي تخصيص اكثر من
2% من نتائجها المحليه الاجمالي للانفاق
العسكري
اجمالا زاد الانفاق العسكري الاوربي بنسبه
19 في المئه خلال العام الماضي مدفوعا
بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
سنناقش هذا الموضوع
في بريطانيا الدكتور بيتر روبرتس كبير
الخبراء في المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدفاعيه
والامنيه اهلا وسهلا بك همم
في الحصاد وابدا معك بهذه المظله العسكريه
الامريكيه التي استفادت منها اوروبا
لسنوات هل الحرب الاوكرانيه
ايقظت اوروبا على ضروره عدم الاعتماد على
هذه المظله انها ليست تدوم لن تدوم للابد
بالنسبه لهم
الاوروبيه
الانفاق العسكريه القضيه هي حقيقه لا يمكن
تعزيز النظام الدفاعي وزياده رفاق عليه في
حين انه منظر ثمانيات اهملوه ولم
يعتلوا الى شراء المعدات العسكريه من
امريكا واماكن اخرى هذه المشكله الحقيقيه
وهي اقناع
القاده الاوروبيين والساس الاوروبيين الان
ينفقوا بنفسه الامد البعيد هناك كثير من
التطورات في الفضاء في المعلومات وكل هذا
كل هذا التطور لم لم حقيقه لم يتم وبقيت
حاجات الحرب التقليديه وبرصت قضيه اوك على
السطح ربما ليس اكثر من اسبوعين قبل الحرب
نفسها وهذا اثار صدمه في اوروبا
ان ترامب كان اول من نادى على الاوروبيين
همم لكي يستيقظوا طالبهم ضروره ايقاف
الاعتماد على الامريكيين وضروره الاعتماد
على انفسهم وزياده وان ينفقوا فعلا بدل ان
يعتمد على الولايات المتحده
في الحقيقه نعم الامر يعود حتى الى ما قبل
ذلك الرئيس
كان يدعو الاوروبيين الى انفاق المزيد ولا
الالتزام بحصته من الانفاق لكنهم لم يفعله
الرئيس ترامب ثم فعل له حقيقه كان التعبير
عن هذا الموقف بشكل اكثر وضوحا بصوت اعلى
من خلال الحديث
المستقبليه عليهم حتى في 2011 عندما قررت
فرنسا بريطانيا انهما ارادته قصف ليبي
اكتشفتانا في خلال يومين نفذت منهما
الذخائر
فقط اريد ان اسال سؤال سريع ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالخلافات داخل الان تحدث عن خلافات
اوروبيه بدرجه الدعم ودرجه همم
السلاح والانفاق ولكن الخلاف داخل كل دوله
نفسها الى اي حد يلعب دور في ايضا تغيير
السياسه
العسكريه
سياسه الانفاق العسكري
نعم نعم
حقيقه لان كل بلد هذه البلدان يعاني
ويكابد الداخليه في تقرير ماذا يريده
الناس والشعب وكيف يقرر الساسه التعامل مع
ذلك ومع تلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا في اداره
الوقت هذا السبب
يواجه اساس صعوبه في اقناع راي العام داخل
البلاد وتربيه الاحتياجات الدفاعي وكما
اشارتهم هناك مواقف متباينه حول كم من
الدعم المالي الذي يجب ان ينفق الالمانهم
الاكثر تلقوا في هذا المجال
الملكي للشؤون الدفاعيه والامنيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
لا املك ما يكفي من الطاقه لاربع سنوات
اخرى هذا ما قالته رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا
امام اعضاء من حزب العمال الذي تنتمي اليه
وهي تعلن انها ستستقيل من منصبها الشهر
المقبل انا انسانه ونحن نعطي كل ما بوسعنا
لاطول فتره ممكنه وبعد ذلك يحين الوقت
بالنسبه لي حان الوقت
من البالغ من العمر 42 عاما والتي تولت
رئاسه الحكومه الاحترافيه عام 2017 هو
موقف لافتفت من سياسيه ورئيسه حكومه يقول
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي انها اظهرت
للعالم كيف تكون القياده بذكائن وقوه
[موسيقى]